how many people were involved when you
started your production company
and then now how many people are
involved when i started
it was me and um my wife
and uh now um it is
me uh with um
one two like four other folks
and a whole bunch of interns um and uh
and a roster of really great um
creatives and directors
so so uh it's become like a little
a little group um and uh
and you know i'm very fortunate of that
to
to find on teammates who who
want to go through through the um
battlefield battlefield of uh being part
of
a production company so we started out
small just
like anyone like you know i'll be
sitting out there going how do people do
it
you know what do you have to do so
i just started it didn't worry about the
equipment
um if there was a bigger job to do
we would rent rent it i didn't want to
buy a
20 30 40 000 worth of equipment and
have it sit there for a year to let it
depreciate and not
get its value so um
so now you know um
you know everything's taking a hit now
with with the pandemic
um even you know we have that we also
have a sales
uh a sales rep that represents um
go pop films and directors in the
midwest and southeast
so what they do is they pitch
the ad agencies and art directors on
our roster of directors and they will
send um
if there are um treatments or
spots or things that we could bid on so
things like that we also go to uh
direct to brand or director companies
you know
that that need video content um but
at the moment just uh things are
obviously production
is that holding it's picking up but
you you want to be safe and we and
that's the key
key uh low overhead keep your overhead
so you
so you could maintain and sustain so
when
when the economy and when comes up
you'll be able
to position yourself so if we think
about it right now
as we are in pre-production that's how
i've
we've talked about it it's like um we're
in pre-production so when production
comes or
we're ready to ready to go so you know
like um being able to
uh service service our clients and
things like that to our best of
our ability i think that's where we're
at right now pandemic
error right and just just with other
booms and busts like let's say the dot
com
um you know when things were really good
in the 90s um it also can you talk about
not getting maybe too confident knowing
that there will be a winter
and there's always a winter you know
yeah i think the
the life cycle the life cycle of uh
of things and that you just have to kind
of
be steady and and and know
especially with with this you might have
a lot of clients
or maybe your business has one big
client but what if they just what if
they
disappear what if your client was a lot
of the travel industry right now
or what if you know where your clients
were
but then what if you weren't busy then
you also you have
you have a plastic company and they're
needing a lot of things so it just
it just all depends where your position
in the market
um changes so you just have to be um
what's this saying uh uh
prepare for the no expect the worst
prepare for the best or
vice versa it's one of those things
where you know you
you can't be a fat cat when you you know
you just kind of like
keep going because there will be lean
times and the same thing with films when
films come out like we just released our
film
uh we don't know
where what the market that's the
toughest thing about filmmaking because
you have a thing that you made you
started three two
four ten years ago but when it reached
market
is it the right time for this film does
this does this touch a nerve
is it is it two years too early two
years too late
so it's the same time when you release a
product is it right or not
maybe it catches on later what was that
with donnie darko
it wasn't so so hot here in the states
it goes
international it comes back it's a five
year five year process
it happens with a lot of different
things so
um so for anyone who's you know
had a short film or other films i think
you'd go back and
focus on that creating because you can't
determine the market
but you can prepare for it i think
that's that's the uh
the balance you have to do you know have
have
have uh be prepared for lean times
and that would be the best way to go
about it
what area of business does your
production company focus on
well we have on a lot of different
directors who
um have whether it's healthcare
food fashion documentary so
so we we covered a lot of different
industries so
we we we could tackle them all
so i figured this out because
when i was you know as me as a director
trying to get on
into a production company i wasn't going
to get hired for
a comedy spot you know because my real
or my work
isn't comedic i was going to get hired
for for
um food because i didn't do any food
you know i had i had a um kind of
documentary
feel those are the different jobs that i
would get
more cinematic so
i thought we will have our company
instead of um turning down
jobs let's find the best directors
who does food who does cars who does
fashion who does products who does um
travel and that's your roster so if
you're
if you're a client that needs um
cinematic images that need to
have your brain or message elevated and
tell a story
that's what we do we want to help you
um uh tell your story and that that's
our selling point
like bringing uh cinematic imagery and
and production
to to elevate your your brand and your
company's message
um so it could be wine
industry it could be um you know
fashion it we pretty much tackle it
how do you know these directors are a
fit for your company first
uh so when we see that the directors
work and and it it has to be a certain
um level and certain sort of um
voice that they're telling uh second i
meet with them
and if they have a similar
um philosophy or personality because we
don't want to work with jerks you know
there's
already so many walking around it's it's
hard it's you know
when we want to work with um good people
who are focused on um and producing
really good work and also um
[Music]
are nice and we had this motto of work
hard and be nice you know
of that aspect so the directors not only
have to be
uh talented they just have to be nice
people because when
you're on set and when you're dealing
with clients
um who wants a temperamental director
or temple it's like we should be
fortunate to be
working for you you know we we
i want to be surrounded people with that
same attitude of like how can we help
you
it's not like i mean business is it's
like
nothing you can't take anything for
granted every little
um every little
job every big job it's a job that should
be treated the same
highly valuable you know um just like i
remember neiman marcus
i think someone was telling me
sales training or someone's training
that you treat everyone who walks
through the door the scene
someone who could look like their
transient versus someone who has a mint
coat
you never know who's who right so that's
the same thing
with an email with a call with if your
client base um we we're just fortunate
to be able to see if we can help you and
that's th that's the type of directors
if they have that attitude and they they
they want to um put their nose to the
grind
um and then they do and funny enough a
lot of our directors have a background
in photography
similar to me so so they they they're
actually started as photographers too so
it's nice to have
um it's just sort of that i know
visually that they
they could capture what they they want
you know they could they could either
act as their own
um dp or work with dps or and things
like that so
funny enough a lot of our directors are
shooters themselves
yeah and what's interesting is too
sometimes
just like you said the mink coat versus
the transient analogy
sometimes in la the mink coat the more
show
the less someone actually yeah you know
that's the weird part about being here
and maybe this is the same in new york
city
too but like a lot of times that's just
a front it's not real you know
exactly and and and you just and
you know you just never know you know
and so
um so those are the type of directors or
or graphic designers or animators or
people we want to work with even in our
crew
and and things like that um i know it
starts
they always say it starts from the top
and hopefully we could
create a culture that that is
professional
but also um
creates that um atmosphere where your
voice is heard
no one's you know above anyone else
everyone's open to suggestions and and
and
and you know uh that one's artistic but
we don't need to be
um van gogh here and be all crazy if
you don't get your way you know what are
your day-to-day duties with your company
maybe pre-covered now during covid
so you get up you know you fire up that
laptop or desktop and then you go
through your emails
a lot right now let's let's talk since
it's really right now
um covid is
research a lot of research that's going
on
uh in terms of uh new
um clients that we
want to kind of work with we're in a new
industry a
we have a um a new industry that we're
we're trying to penetrate
is the the golf and luxury resort
industry
prior to covid uh we've got a great
couple great directors who who do that
so we're trying to
match match match that up now that's the
commercial side but for the film
um the film side uh
is uh we have a couple
i have a couple different films in the
in development right now
and one uh one um is
uh we're developing the script
um or just shaping it up to be to go out
um for um attachments and things like
that so the last
couple of months i've been trying to get
that script right
and then and then and then also we're
also
you know producing um this uh
feature film for uh yifki
she's a dutch filmmaker it'll be her
first
feature film uh she her her short film
lily
has been screened over 50 film festivals
around the world it's a me too horror
film
in her and phosphor is one of her um
first feature film
we're fortunate enough to be producing
that so we're trying to get
things lined up for that as well so
like we were talking about before
there's still a lot of things that could
be done
even though we're not everyone's getting
used to zoom and all this stuff but it's
it's laying laying the seeds and and
and um getting that all done so that
takes most of the day
and also preparing for um we just
released the film
like two weeks or two you know september
25th
um last month and then um so we're
still pushing that as well you know um
so a lot
lots of little different things on on
our plate
and so maybe pre covid was it responding
and and and and post covet or during
covet is now
hunting doing research yeah hunting
doing research um and and because you
because you don't know who's going to be
um left standing it's a weird thing you
know even
when we're talking with our sales agent
who
who we've released our film for north
america
but we're still um you know entertaining
international territories like germany
uk ireland
and all these other parts but
but because of the pandemic of things
different companies have gone under
who's things so
it's almost like everyone's waiting to
see um
what's what's left who's standing
where's the you know um
so they're you know everyone's adjusting
and it's it
and so you kind of have to take a
um optimistic um point and um
and and do your research and and tread
water
um until there's a break you know
yeah it's so it's very interesting well
i mean for commercial
commercial work we used to um you know
we had a lot of shoots postponed
you know cancel and things like that so
uh
um you know you you do you deal with the
blows and
you know you you take it take it with a
chin but you
you guys still stand up and prepare
as as when things open up
you